-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, everyone's
talking about this.
A federal judge has overruled
the CDC's mask mandate
for planes,
and now all the major airlines
have dropped their
mask requirements.
But don't worry,
to keep everyone safe,
you can now bring only up to
3.4 ounces of COVID on board.
-Oh.
-That's correct.
[ Laughter ]
To put it another way,
airlines are basically turning
off the seatbelt sign for COVID
and telling it to move freely
about the cabin.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, if you thought
Omicron was bad,
wait till you meet
the Spirit variant.
[ Laughter ]
Whoo.
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-When the news broke,
some pilots actually
announced the news midflight,
and people started celebrating.
This is true.
Yeah, passengers were dancing,
hugging, kissing,
and now they're all
in quarantine.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, there was a crazy scene
on American Airlines.
People tore off their masks
and shoved them
right into the ashtrays.
[ Laughter ]
How old is this plane?
Yeah.
And it's not just planes.
Amtrak has also ended
their mask mandate.
Right now train conductors
are celebrating
by punching 25 tiny holes
in their masks.
[ Imitates punch clicking ]
[ Laughter ]
"Can I have your mask, please?"
[ Imitates punch clicking ]
[ Light laughter ]
Right now also Uber
has announced
that they're dropping
all mask requirements.
Honestly, I'm going to miss
getting into
a masked stranger's car.
It was kind of fun
to play that game --
my ride to the airport
or kidnapping?
You know?
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, the White House
isn't happy with the ruling.
They called it disappointing
and urged travelers
to keep wearing masks,
but they said that they're
not fighting the decision.
It's kind of like your parents
when you tell them
about your new tattoo.
[ Laughter ]
"I don't know
if you're going to like
'Suite Life of Zack and Cody'
in 20 years.
But go for it.
Get the tattoo.
Hope for a reunion."
Speaking of the White House,
I read that President Biden
has told former president Obama
that he plans to run
for re-election in 2024.
Biden was like,
"I'll consider the long,
silent stare your blessing."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that was a good one.
Yeah, that's a good joke.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Obama actually had
some good advice.
He was like, "Be careful.
After two terms,
people might say you look old."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, you guys see this?
French President Emmanuel Macron
is running for re-election,
and a photo of him
is going viral
'cause he's showing
a ton of chest hair.
Take a look.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Yeah.
There he is.
Well, it's inspired Macron to
test some new campaign slogans.
Check these out.
First up, there's...
Next up, there's...
-Whoa!
-And finally, there's...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey!
-Oh!
-Hey!
-Macron.
-Apparently the people of France
love the photo
and it's become very popular.
I guess that explains
what I saw earlier today.
-E15 is about 10 cents a gallon
cheaper than E10.
And some gas stations offer...
[ Laughter ]
-It works.
I like it.
Approval rating up.
-Yeah.
-Some more news.
Former president Trump
just released a statement
saying that Russia and Ukraine
should try to reach an agreement
to end the war.
[ Light laughter ]
When they heard that,
Miss America contestants
were like, "Nailed it."
Yeah.
Great answer.
Yep, Trump was like,
"After eight weeks,
I've now come to realize
this is a no bueno."
[ Laughter ]
Switching gears,
this is interesting.
Scientists in Japan
came up with a creative way
to get people to eat less salt.
Check this out.
-Researchers in Japan hope their
new taste-enhancing chopsticks
will make healthy food
low in salt taste better.
The high-tech utensils
are hooked up
to a special computer device
on the user's wrist,
which causes
a small electric current
to flow through
what they're eating,
activating any sodium ions
and allowing for their tongue
to taste more salt
than is actually in the food.
[ Light laughter ]
-Wow, it's just that simple!
[ Laughter ]
Anyone else see a problem
combining soup and electricity?
[ Laughter ]
If you want to save time, just
pour the soup over your head
and plug yourself into a wall.
Well, this is going viral.
A woman in the U.K. was at
brunch with her friends, okay?
And she tried to get her jacket
that fell behind
the booth, okay?
And let's just --
let's see how that went.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering ]
She was --
She fell behind the --
-Three songs.
-Yeah, that's three --
Was it three songs?
-Yes.
-Can I just see that
one more time?
She fell behind the thing.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It makes sense
because the bar she was at
was called Bottoms Up.
[ Laughter ]
You know brunch
went off the rails
when someone does a keg stand
without a keg.
Do you know what I'm saying?
After they got her up,
she was like,
"Alright, so now we know
11 mimosas is my limit.
Okay."
Also, it was nice of her friends
to spring into action
and help her record it,
don't you think?
[ Laughter ]
I heard about a woman
in Massachusetts
who was learning to drive
in a cemetery
and crashed into
eight headstones.
[ Light laughter ]
It's just weird that her
driving instructor was like,
"Try a U-turn at Edna Doyle's
final resting place
and then parallel park
by the mausoleum."
Yep. So between that and getting
stuck behind a booth,
she had a real tough day.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Alright, so this is "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we
should post on Twitter, okay?
Now, I'm going to show you
five different tweets,
and we're all gonna vote
on whether you like each one
or not, okay?
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You can vote for all of them
if you like.
You can vote for none of them
Whatever you want, and we're
going to see the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you also have clickers.
-Yes.
-Have you ever been correct
on these?
-No, I haven't.
-No?
Higgins, have you?
-No.
-No? Okay, maybe tonight
will be successful.
-Tonight, this is my night.
-You can vote yes or no,
yea or nay.
Whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out
live on the show
so you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it.
[ Laughter ]
It's a shared experience.
You guys ready for this?
The first --
The first tweet is...
-[ Laughs ]
-Wow.
I can already kind of tell.
-I like it.
-I like it, too.
I just feel like it's --
The silence is a thumbs-down.
-It's humor.
-Okay.
I think the -- the votes are in.
And now let's see
the results here.
Yeah, no.
They did not like that.
-Wow.
-Resounding no.
No, thanks.
No air horn.
[ Imitates air horn ]
This next one is...
[ Laughter ]
-Come on, that's good, too.
-Make your vote.
Yeah, here we go.
Now let's see the results
on this one here.
What do you think of that one?
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think they went a little
too heavy on that one.
-Yeah, that's 160.
I voted yes.
-Yeah, here we go.
Alright.
This next one is...
[ Light laughter ]
[ Jazz music plays ]
Not for you?
-Not for me.
I don't care for that.
I don't care for
that type of humor.
-Let's see the results
on that one there.
Let's see what we got.
Yeah, no. I agree.
I agree with this one.
This next one, though, I --
-You like this next one?
-Well, again, I don't want
to pick favorites,
but you can vote for all of them
or none of them.
That's the rule.
Or you can put
your clickers down.
You can go, "I don't
feel like doing this."
Yeah, "I came here
to be entertained.
I don't want to entertain you."
-"I don't want to work.
Why don't you decide
what tweet it is?"
-Here we go.
Here's the tweet here.
Next up is...
[ Laughter ]
-Is "Twinkie" a euphemism
for something?
-No, no, it is not.
No, it is not.
-Okay. I'm sorry.
-No, it is not.
It's a --
-Twinkie.
-It's a Hostess --
-It's kind of tan-colored tube.
-Yes.
-Filled with cream.
Got it.
-Alright.
-This is a family show.
I'm voting no.
Disgusting.
-Let's see the results
on that one right there.
-Whoa!
-Oh, boy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
-I think it's a good idea.
I think it's a good gag.
Someone yawns,
you shove a Twinkie.
-Sure. A Hostess.
Hostess comes over.
-The last one here is...
[ Laughter ]
-Shhhh!
-That's pretty good.
Yeah, I like that one, too.
Okay, everyone.
Let's see the results right now.
Right there.
Yeah. Not bad.
Alright, I think we know.
Looks like the winner is...
Yes!
I'm going to post this
during the commercial break.
Thank you for helping me out.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "WeTweet," and enjoy.